it says find the coordinates of the
points of inflection okay now again I'm
actually not going to focus on this too
much in terms of the writing of the
working you guys can it's actually quite
lengthy but what I want to remind you of
is how to search for a point of
inflection what's the main thing you're
looking for what's the point of
inflection what is the definition of a
point election anyway the yeah the point
of inflection a point inflection means a
change in concavity you went from
concave up to concave down or the other
way round okay so what's the easiest way
to search for such changes in concavity
you're going to use this guy right now
just watch out it's been a while since
we focused on this I know you guys know
to look for when this is zero right but
it's not the only time when you can get
a point of inflection this something
else this can become that may be a point
inflection is they don't remember it is
I've got a big clue on the board okay
this may be zero or no value like there
might be a discontinuity in the second
derivative and this is the classic you
can level my class has seen this to
death but maybe if you came from another
class you haven't seen it before this
guy is the cube root of x okay so if
you're looking at the cube root of x
chuckling desmos if you'd like to
convince yourself there is a point of
inflection it goes from up to down in
can cavity but when you try out the
derivatives right there's why - there's
why double - okay you quickly realize
that that second sorry that point of
inflection zero you can't put it in here
why not what happens when you put 0 into
this see that minus sign on that index
that means that the way you could write
this is minus 2 over 9 X to the 5/3
there's an X on the bottom you put 0
into that and it just explodes in your
face right but there's a point of
inflection okay so we're looking for
zeros or discontinuities are there any
discontinuities on this have a look have
a look it's a it's a question it's a
rational function what kinds of things
would give you a discontinuity for
something like this they tend to come
from the denominator right dividing by
zero just like
we looked at but see this denominator
it's never ever zero no matter what
value of x that you put in if you've got
real numbers you won't get zero okay so
that's good I don't have to worry about
that but there are two spots when it's
zero what are they you can see it from
here can't you have a look where's my
gun
you're going to get your points
inflection that's why at x equals 1 what
1 and negative 1 because that's a
difference of squares in there yeah when
you get negative 1 and 1 what Y values
do you get for them have you found them
already so do I got them we're going
back to this original function right so
you put 1 and negative 1 in here
I think you're gonna get you're gonna
get lon - right so right am I done that
in my head now just the quick note I've
got the same thing for both that's
suspicious I should have I didn't get
asked the question by this but I should
have been a little bit clued into the
fact that see there's a 1 plus x squared
see how that's an even power so what
kind of function what kind of symmetry
is gonna have it's going to have even
symmetry it looks the same on both sides
okay now I'm ready to sketch the curve
I've got a stationary point if you
haven't already get your set of axes and
pop your stationary point on there now
at that point because it's a minimum
which you guys found earlier I know it's
going to be concave up right so I'm
going to have something facing upward at
this point and I also know that there
are two points of inflection here one
log - so let's call that one let's go
log 2 up here so there's a point of
inflection there and because you guys
had actually gone and you've tested you
did your neighborhood test right you've
got the table values there you know it
goes from concave up to concave down on
this side it must be concave down right
you're getting the same thing but in
Reverse over here because this is
negative 1 log 2 it's going to go from
concave down to concave up
yeah what's the picture look like he is
my minimum right I've got to get up to
there like that it's messy but forgive
me and then I'm going to change from
cavities so it sort of changes like that
okay now over here how do I know how do
you know that it never comes back there
never loose back down I could have gone
for x-intercepts however at this point
I've not actually worked to find any now
it as it happens this graph doesn't ever
come below zero but I don't I haven't
done anything to establish that yet if
it were to come back around and turn
round what would I have found earlier in
order to turn around you'd have to be
stationary would you not but I've only
got one stationary point so this never
comes back down it just kind of slows
down forever like that okay can't turn
because I would've found something that
would have told me that it's an even
function yeah so therefore once you've
got the right-hand side I know what the
left-hand sides gonna look like there
you go okay
this is the second to last part this guy
is y equals log of 1 plus x squared read
object very strange but that's what
calculus is for before calculus you'd be
like I have no idea
thank God for desmos right okay well we
don't need to do it anymore we've got
the answers last part
sketch that guy now have a look
think back to what we've been doing
recently it says hence it says hence so
everything I just did is going to be
designed to help me get this okay what
can I do with this to help me see its
relationship to this can someone tell me
what more can you take advantage of
we've already used it like a couple of
times today yeah I can separate this
quotient this log into two logs right so
it's going to be this oh that looks
familiar right take away log 2 okay so
that's not a coincidence
is it right see how these guys are up at
log two you're going to drag them down
so where are they going to hit
exactly on the axis right what about
this guy used to be zero zero where
you're going to drag it down log two so
it'll be down on my scale I guess it
would be their negative load - is that
okay so now I just take the rest of the
shape and hey presto okay so that was a
lot of work yes cuz it's a complicated
graph and you've got to do a lot of
machinery to get there but that's part
of why for instance you can see it says
show that they really want you to get
this shape right so if you were to
differentiate and they're like oh no I
found the wrong derivative you're kind
of stuck so that's why they give it to
you okay you guys know if you see a
question like this even if you can't get
those derivatives the question hands it
to you so you could say in Part C for
instance I've run out of time to do Part
B but you told me that this is true so I
can use it for Part C and so on and so
on okay